yeah I just I just remembered as we were
like going for a toilet break there was
one other like Awkward Moment uh go on
okay so we we we're in the girls bar and
they had like a few like magazine
promotions for uh different Idol groups
uh in Japan and so uh my mum asks oh
what what is that and I go oh uh that's
like they're promoting like an auto
group in Japan it's a pretty popular
culture in Japan and she asked her
what's an idol group and I'm like oh
that's a rabbit hole I'm like how do I
how do I how do I begin to explain this
is this like is this like a child or
like underground Idol group or like a
mainstream Idol group I'll be honest I
haven't known I don't know do you want
to explain the difference to me Joey
because I don't I don't know it's like
imagine if BTS wasn't that popular and
they were more about catering to
individual fans it's the difference
between like is it promoting like you
know [__] Imagine Dragons or some
like lesser known like SoundCloud artist
you know that's that's the difference or
it's like they both have their fan bases
but one is like more you know in the
mainstream and like you know TV and [__]
and then there are ones where it's like
they play at local venues to like very
small crowds but they still have a
dedicated fan base kind of thing right
because that's the best way to explain
yeah the best uh the way I ended up
explaining it was like okay so it's kind
of like it's it's kind of like a music
group that caters towards a very
specific audience that they try to get
as invested in this group as possible in
order to spend money and that's a very
light it's a very arbitrary way of
saying it though uh yeah because I I was
I was like how do I explain like Idol
culture and then like Midway through
Midway through my shitty explanation
then she goes they look very young
well yeah typically like 19 to 25.
you're correct on that mother yeah yeah
she was like yeah they look very young I
was like yeah and then she was like they
look like very very young and I was just
like I I paused for a second and I was
just like do I want to open this can of
worms pause for a second and I just go
yes
[Music]
are you sure you should have just said
like oh you know all Japanese women
when someone spend enough time around
they're like
what's up with all the kids stuff
I've had a few friends say that when
they've been here yeah yeah that's true
so what's up with that and I'm like well
that is a uh cultural can of worms yeah
we can talk about we're going to be here
I don't want to explain yeah for like
six hours yeah yeah yeah but that was
that was like yeah I'm looking forward
to seeing what other parts of Japanese
culture I'm going to have to explain
can't wait for your Sydney's mom to be
like I want to go see these Idol groups
I was having dinner with someone and uh
they they asked me they were like so why
does it seem like nobody's really
friends here and I'm like okay well no
that's uh that's like eight layers of
culture yeah dissect we're like going
back to school we're talking about the
work culture we're going through
everything and it was just like a whole
I realized when I was speaking about it
I was like I should just said something
dumb like I don't really like friends
yeah I kind of realized oh yeah am I
being that guy am I being that guy
that's just like going way too deep into
like a topic over like just a simple
question yeah today at all I don't know
if you had this because I I went to a
restaurant with someone who's visiting
and I was like I told them uh because I
was like I can just order if you want
because I was like I was like they're
gonna freak out if you say something
that they don't understand yeah yeah and
he was like why and I was like I don't
[__] know why because they like they
like the script they like everything
that happens in the way they want it to
happen Okay I don't know why but just
let me order so they don't freak out and
it doesn't get weird and they tried to
order and he they try to take the menu
and he's like no no I want to keep on to
it and they're like what
he was like what do I do I was like just
I was like it's okay we'll just eat
we'll look at the menu it's fine yeah
this is how games must feel when like
speed Runners stop breaking yeah
genuinely what do we do I've clipped
into the restaurant and I've already got
them like yeah I wonder if they'll come
across that at all yeah I I did give
them I did give them a little bit of
advice that uh like backfired a bit
because how do you explain how do you
explain the Japanese accent to someone
who doesn't understand I would say say
it in a very slow way
like you would say yeah like you don't
say cream cheese you say
just say it slower like cream cheese and
they might they'll put it together yeah
sometimes as well the the people who
you're talking to
because you're obviously very clearly
look foreign yeah they're expecting you
to say in the foreign way anyway yeah so
sometimes if you say it in the Japanese
way they kind of get confused weirdly I
know it sounds literally me every time
it sounds hard yeah it sounds hard to
believe genuinely like it's like when
you're uh like when you're in like
you're in the UK or something you're in
like a country and then you overhear a
conversation and you're like that
sounded like a different language but it
wasn't right it's weird I don't know how
no I get it like sometimes the
expectation messes with what you're like
actually hearing yeah so I mean I get
that with Korean a lot like uh there's a
there's been so many instances where I
would hear someone in public like what I
think is them speaking Japanese but it's
actually Korean and vice versa yeah yeah
and it's and it's bizarre every single
time it happens the one that's even
weirder is when I think they're speaking
Korean but they're actually speaking in
Japanese no I've heard that as well I've
overheard conversations I think they
think speaking a foreign language yeah
for some reason that how my brain heard
those words but no they were speaking
English yeah it's so weird I get that
with Vietnamese a lot like every time I
hear Vietnamese especially Vietnamese
um I I like I like look up because I'm
like oh someone's speaking time and then
I've realized it's a completely
different language right it's like
they're saying words I should understand
but it's just it's something about it
just doesn't comprehend in my mind I
think what it is is like the inflections
are similar yeah but the words exactly
like the same with currently like the
with Korean is like the inflection is so
close to Japanese but it's just the
words and like some sounds they make are
just like oh that's not Japanese yeah
the [__] is that the [__] is that yeah I
think have you ever seen that video
where it's kind of like it's like what
English sounds like to people who don't
speak English that's exactly like I love
that video that's that video just like
unlocked another part of my brain to
realize oh okay I get it now yeah I this
is this is what people hear because
that's kind of a very similar feeling to
why here when I hear someone speaking
Vietnamese I'm like oh wait tight no why
when I understand this what yeah it's
pretty interesting when I go to Vietnam
for the first time actually yeah yeah
yeah because uh you're going you're
going for the first time in Vietnam this
year as well aren't you yes yeah I'm
going to uh Vietnam for my mum's 60th
birthday because uh for some reason I'm
the only one in my family who's never
been to Vietnam my sister has been like
four she's like hiked across Vietnam
what like a number of times during
school and like my parents have been
like four or five times and I'm like I
put the food I'm like where the [__] was
my invite
yeah so I'm looking for it I'm
definitely two weeks Southeast Asian
food sounds so good Vietnam's gonna be
lit it's gonna be so good I'm so excited
for it that's not happening for a while
but yep yeah yeah so I've learned my
lesson next time okay next time I'll
I'll recommend Google translate oh I did
recommend it oh okay okay yeah four like
menus and stuff
um I was I was just saying just in case
uh you need to like enunciate something
I'm like how can I how can how can I
explain Katakana the Katakana kind of
like English you know yeah now because
like now I realize if I want to explain
to someone if they're into weeb culture
just just say it just be like say it in
what you think is like anime we just
turn full weave just turn forward and
don't afraid to turn because I've seen
people the real the reason I realize I
went down this route because because
I've seen people go down the route of
just saying the words slower but just
completely like keeping the English
accents yeah like like when I've seen
some people like try to order like Coke
or something Coca-Cola and they say Coke
Coca-Cola and and then they then they
try to say slowly and it's still like
Coca-Cola and you know that doesn't
register yeah you say quarter you know
which is like yeah more Japanese like
Katakana kind of accent people get that
and the best way I can kind of like
describe that is that it just sounds
what you think we sound like you know I
don't know how else to explain it I had
that I had that happen to a uni friend
of mine who I brought to Japan for the
first time yeah we were at a Starbucks
and he wanted to get a milk tea and uh
and he was at the front and he's like oh
can I get one milk tea please you know
super Australian yeah and the one was
just like uh what the [__] did you just
say yeah and then he turned to me and
he's like how do you say milk tea in
Japanese and I'm like
here's the thing right so he turned
around like it's just like
here's what I've learned from from
learning a language right if you don't
speak the language do not say other
words other than the thing you are
trying to convey yes like if you want a
milk tea at a Starbucks don't say can I
have a milk tea just say milk tea yeah
because then what you're trying to
you're putting emphasis on the
communication of just this one thing
you're not because it's gonna scare them
if you say all this other [__] they're
like oh what about a milk tea like do
you want me to throw it away like yeah
you know what I mean like obviously it's
not there but like you're adding in
confusion well they might not even hear
the word yeah yeah so it's like just say
the thing you want I know it's gonna
make you feel like an idiot but you are
you don't speak the language you're
basically a toddler speak like what you
would put into a Google search bar
basically yeah yeah it's like just the
keywords only that's all you need yeah
but yeah I mean Japan is getting a lot
more Katakana in its vocab in everyday
use but it's it's such a gamble you
never know which words they're using
yeah yeah like certain words you're like
why okay they chose this word all right
cool like uh like they use the word
um
sometimes they use the word assist
sometimes yeah sometimes
the [__] assist like why was that the
word you chose to bring over I think
that's probably because of sports maybe
yeah and like task task they use task a
lot yeah yeah they use
this is multitasking yeah
yeah it's weird the words they choose to
bring over and the words that they they
often uh try and integrate into the
language yeah it's not just English
words either that they do that for so
yeah yeah true you know they use like
arubaito which is the German one yeah
you know that's a that's an odd choice
or like uh [__] punk all right for
bread oh yeah as well for like uh bell
peppers like those are all European
words I didn't know that yeah yeah and
then luckily in Starbucks you could say
soy milk yeah
it's just so annoying to say yeah it's
such a necessarily long word for you
Junior the soy milk it's just no Union's
just milk oh sorry sorry it's a Tonia
you can just say
yeah
that's like that's like uh like fromage
for us in English it's like it's like
the fancy version of cheese
in France and they're like
oh get a load of this guy you're getting
the soy milk lattice dude
sometimes you do go to like the French
places and you should actually see like
at the kind of fromage yes you get
[__] though because you're like you're
reading the Katakana in a French
restaurant and it's Katakana for French
yeah you're like [__] I didn't know this
[__] about French
that [__] me up so many times but like
if it was in England if it was like in
the the Roman alphabet French I can
normally kind of figure out a little bit
what they're talking about because I'm
like I know these letters kind of the
boys they make so I can kind of put it
together but if you see like
you're just like what the [__] is that
yeah
but I had a friend who uh uh white guy
married to an Asian woman and when he
went to I think it was like France or
Germany he said like oh yeah it is a
little bit of an advantage knowing
English because you can kind of figure
out roughly kind of what the stuff is
from the words right because you can
read it yeah you can maybe maybe not
German but like French you can kind of
figure out roughly what they're maybe
saying yeah you're like ah it's a it's
an omelette I think yeah
yeah it's Advantage and whereas you know
if you're used to eating Chinese
characters or Japanese it's a lot harder
to be like wow okay what the [__] am I
reading yeah exactly you don't even have
like anything close to a frame of
reference to like build off of you know
and then on top of that with like at
least Japan is great with signs they put
signs everywhere and symbols they love
putting symbols everywhere in in the UK
holy [__] we don't got [__] you got
nothing in the countryside good luck
that's true actually yeah I didn't
realize that until you said that like
you don't realize how like almost far in
a friendly Tokyo at times with how how
good it is for helping you get around
yeah uh and and how how they prefer to
use like one pictures outside and and
plastic models and stuff like yeah dude
it's so nerve-wracking going into like a
restaurant in the UK or in France
because you're like bro I don't know
what the menu is I have no idea I can't
read any of them because a lot more
often they don't even show you the menu
yeah so you're just like I don't [__]
know if it's good I'll find it when I
get in and then there's no pictures not
that I needed pictures I'm not a toddler
I don't know what the stuff is but it
would be nice to kind of see the
portions and the size yeah like a frame
of reference yeah we're working with
here I want to see because sometimes
people make like certain dishes and they
look like ass and then other places the
pigeon looks amazing it looks good I
want that thing for sure for sure
yeah but uh that's that's been pretty
much everything I've been up to